my value is what the hell i think my
values and it's your choice to spend
your money on it or not
but i'm not i used to just 35
ahead for a thing this that i'm like
what the [ __ ] one of the best quotes
that i've ever heard
was my prizes aren't based on what you
can afford it's based on what i'm worth
that's one of the the best quotes i've
ever heard
yes and like because people try to
nickel and dime everybody
comes with that when you're trying to
train fighting
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
cheers my friend we have a very special
guest
and you know being part of the food
world i always love bringing food people
into this podcast
and actually i i haven't actually
watched
uh masterchef after like the fourth
season you know
but only because i started [ __ ]
hating that one guy
what's his name justin the bald [ __ ]
italian [ __ ] what's up oh
joe joe bastianich i [ __ ] hate that
guy
i hate him with everything that i have
there's a lot of people that have the
same feelings that you have about joe
first of all because here's the thing
he's always been good to me
joe has always been good but a lot of
people do have a lot of problems with
joe it's just the way that he speaks
either he's doing it through for
theatrics but the weird thing is this
right
you have two chefs on there right you
have gordon ramsay and you have um arone
yes and then you have this man
he's a restaurateur right but he speaks
as if he's the best chef on earth this
is very true you're a [ __ ]
restaurateur
correct you shut the [ __ ] up this guy
sits here he eats this [ __ ] food and
here's the thing he doesn't give
constructive criticism i think that's
what i hate about him on the show he
eats it and he goes
this is trash why is it trash you bald
[ __ ]
i love the i love i see i'm an analytics
guy so
that's one thing about uh gordon and our
own them being chefs they would tell you
exactly kind of
why it needs is this needs more acid
this needs more salt maybe the
temperature's just that more hard seer
i do agree with that that joe's
criticism was definitely
way less constructive i need something
by the way
introduce yourself i'll i'll introduce
you first this is noah sims from
master chef season 10. right season 10.
so [ __ ] him i just wanted to put it out
there
you might like him and now i don't know
absolutely i love people always
shooting from the hip i mean it to each
of their own
let me ask you something on that show
hit me with him
who do you hate the most out of all
three judges
i don't hate anybody but definitely just
like joe
aron was always gordon is such a
powerhouse he is such a
cool cat like yeah when you get around
gordon
like it's there's just like everything's
gonna be okay like it's bob marley's
playing like when he's around
everything's gonna be okay like no
matter what kind of situation i'm in in
the kitchen
this guy's like you know russell crowe
master and commander like we are going
to be okay
so arone is a goofball that i liked the
way his style always constructive always
helping hands-on approach
um and then joe like you said as a
restaurateur
more more abrasive uh i'm sure when he
hears this he'll love to hear that but
um the the thing that i
like the best about um
the judge selection was was you could
really tell
when they were really trying to help
like you could tell when there was
reality about it but then you could tell
when it was like they're saying the heck
with the re like this is really here we
are like yeah this is really
what i want um and our own aron
and gordon were exceptional at that yeah
i i enjoyed both of them thoroughly and
i didn't have a problem with joe as well
um he was always i think very open with
me but
a lot of other times he would of course
come off as exactly how you're saying
like where
where the hell are you getting that like
why would you say it like
that like you're like speaking in
blanket statements like could you be a
little bit more exact with that comment
just a little bit more pinpoint that's
how i always felt when he was
because it wasn't critiques it was just
insults and i'm like
you gotta say you gotta give them
something you can't just say
i don't understand why you would do this
this is the dumbest thing i've ever seen
you're right no and i say that to any i
would say that's anything i think you're
100 accurate on that and it's like what
is
for me on any show it's like
if i'm going to give criticism in
anything in life
i believe that if you're going to strike
it you need to be able to like where are
you coming from i feel like well some
people don't earn that's like well then
just
don't say anything like i'm going to say
this
you me monster and i'm going to get this
off of my chest and i'm gonna feel
better but it's like where is this
helping me at it's like you're just
doing that for you you're not doing this
for me
like you're supposed to be a coach a
coach is supposed to be able to benefit
the student and the people so this is
for you or for me
yeah so you're you're right on that
point but how did you get okay
so if for those of you who don't watch
uh masterchef i watched the first four
seasons and intermittently i've been in
and out watching the other episodes
like masterchef is interesting because
it's not
it's not um famous chefs it's
you guys are originally like home cooks
right that have a very unique talent
when it comes to food
what is the selection process how did
you get uh selected for the show
you know you're gonna have you're gonna
have so many different stories
of people um because there's so many
different ways they've done it mine was
just such a
big story like so many chapters
i mean it was a long process some people
were like vip where they like
saw him off instagram and they like
boosted them through the first couple
rounds and things like that
my buddy uh gave me a
message on facebook and said this is 13
miles from your house don't be a [ __ ]
go out there because we want to see if
you're as good as we think you are so
i was like game on and then whenever i
went out there for me
it was it was a i want to get there 30
minutes early
i'm going to be i'm going to be one of
the first ones
little did i know little guy know that
there'd be like hundreds and thousands
of people going to these things and it
was absurd because excuse me
because you saw so many different people
different walks of life flying in from
all over the country like where are you
from was like 13 minutes down the road
like
like i'm from ohio like jesus is crying
like you like where did you stay like
below the airport and this this this
like okay
well like whatever and you're supposed
to for the first step you're supposed to
bring
a dish that you could prepare five
minutes before
like set it up but it had to be hot
served hot cold served cold
and you had no microwave anything like
that so i was like well that's an easy
one for me i was like i can control the
temperature of
cold a lot more than hot because i'll
just have it in a cooler like i'll just
bring my coolant because you can bring a
cooler
yeah instead of trying like thermosing a
soup or something
some of the stuff people were bringing
was so asinine someone brought these
grit sticks with guacamole and they were
hardened they were cold
so i made i made a steak beef tartare
made this little beautiful
i i had everything measured plazed out
so as soon as i said five minutes i had
my homemade french baguettes
whipped it together with my mustard my
capers all this stuff and it was
perfectly set
making making making my impact
was running analytics the whole time
from the get-go from the first room
which had hundreds of people to walking
up the stairs seeing that they were
handing
signs out wanting to see your
personality immediately i read straight
through that they're like like take a
picture and they're hanging this random
prop and i'm like
freaking like a crazy person and like
getting everyone to laugh
and then i literally was walking into
every room being like thinking that
there's very very important people in
this room pretending like they're not
very important
so like i'm perusing the room and then
all of a sudden i run into two british
accents and i'm like okay well that
jumps off the page is different
than everybody else in here like okay i
might be onto something here
after we did the cook or whatever we
went to two it went from 80 to 40 to 20
and they split to 10 and 10. when we
walk in the 10 and 10
natalica and jen who are the executive
producers of masterchef were two of the
people i already met
in the room before because i was
introducing myself and talking to
everybody
what i do uh i got onto the top five
there they gave me a ticket i'm thinking
all right i'm going to la it's great no
there's like freaking like
five or six more meetings i had there's
like a 564 question psych evaluation
test
really multiple multiple multiple
uh we did two two
huge uh sessions of psychologists
separate psychologists
uh and i was like but yeah they are
trying to they're trying to make no
crazy people get on there but i was like
no they're not they're balancing the
crazy because some of the sons of
[ __ ] that are on there
are absolutely bat [ __ ] insane so they
were trying to get a good balance yeah
yeah
young on that so uh
it was a hell of a process doing videos
sending videos in
just constantly those months and months
and months and then finally like hey
listen
we want you to come to l.a yeah the
process is that [ __ ]
long time yes months and months and
months and then you get these people on
there
there's one for me maybe you're
different but like you get the people
that are like i've heard them people get
on podcasts like yeah i was a vip
they kind of got me through the thing
and this and that yeah i was like
why are you bragging about like what
don't you want to like say like you
started down at the bottom
here yeah it's like yeah i was falsely
inflated and uh you know my value i
didn't actually finish very good on the
show
but uh you know they thought i was going
to be good so they were me monster on
vip
i hear that all the time well you know
you find out too like just in anything
in life there's
i think people are better at talking
about what they do than actually doing
it oh my gosh
especially because like social media now
right yeah and um
like i see this a lot just with i mean
even restaurants are like that
right because the the instagram game is
so [ __ ] popular
yes you can make something look as good
as you want on a picture but when you
get there
the expectation versus reality is very
[ __ ] different but well you're going
to get really excited than when i tell
you one of the cool things i'm going to
be doing
oh really so yeah today i did the h2o is
as a h2 now has half a million on tick
tock and the guy that we were with was
liam he's got two and a half million or
whatever
pretty big accounts uh instagram
uh age who's i think 80 000. but they're
starting to really gonna go up
um the
what what we've got going on is trying
to get
a a a basically a
a set mark where we're able to start
building this um
[Music]
like community or whatever trying to get
that rolling and coming out here
coming out here has been such a game a
game-changing experience for like coming
out here and seeing y'all and like
feeling that energy last night and
getting things rolling
yeah man it's pandemic right now dude
this is nothing
well no but that's but it's been no but
it's been really awesome kind of seeing
like the the content creations and
things like that and trying to
make the content i know i don't do i
don't do all the
super content things i'm like building
and building and building and slowly
trying to get better
just and them are fantastic at that
though so you're from
uh cleveland ohio no he's no the guy
that was over here liam was actually
from cleveland i'm from
north georgia blue ridge oh okay blue
ridge georgia
so i mean the scene in the vibe is so
different
you know nine day nine day because like
you know food scene too is
is so different out here like one of the
things that i love about like la's food
scene
is that we have a lot of towns here that
have been around here for a while
yeah so i make this comparison to new
york a lot cause i go to new york a lot
like i love new york's food scene a lot
but the thing that i think la does
differently from uh
new york is that we don't believe in the
seasonal vegetable [ __ ]
like in in k-town you're not going to
see a seasonal vegetable pop up in this
mom and pop korean shop they're like i
don't give a [ __ ] what your seasonal
vegetable is
this is lovely sticking sticking to what
you know sticking what's real
so if you go to like this peruvian joint
they're not going to put
the hot new item out right now into
their menu this is what we've had
this is what you get if not you go [ __ ]
off i love that no
i love that you know this the food scene
is so different
really it's so different in the state of
georgia
there's a section right above atlanta
which when you come visit me
uh in georgia i'm gonna blow your mind
but it
right above atlanta is a beaufort
highway okay
and i swear to god you could take a
two-mile stretch of that
and get 10 restaurants that are going to
be 100 family owners freaking
generationally
family owned of different you could get
like a a sri lankan
a korean a guatemalan a chinese
some of the best dead guys i've been
around the world a couple times i've
eaten a lot of really good food i've
been so blessed with being able to eat
some of the best food on the planet
and i'm telling you what the food that
kicks out of that dead gum
two miles of beaufort high i mean some
of the best
some of the best bon me's which i'm a
huge bond me i love a great vietnamese
bon me sandwich like three dollars if
you buy five of them they give you one
for free
so you get literally six of these giant
sandwiches for fifteen dollars
cash and they're just the best
sandwiches have you been out over here
in uh like the sgv no i'm not that's all
that [ __ ] over there see we don't have
anything else though but just
you just have that in georgia you have
that and then nothing else in la
you have literal like just
well you know 30 miles this way 30 miles
that way we got like
one little wheelhouse in georgia well
it's interesting because like
years ago like because i used to i grew
up eating bunnies right so in sacramento
california which is like i don't know
like 400 miles from here right
it's state capital but they have a huge
vietnamese community out there
so back in the day bun meat sandwiches
were a dollar 25.
so what [ __ ] sandwich was a dollar 25
obviously because of inflation it's not
like two to three bucks right but i grew
up
like my parents would just have like
lunch for us and it was four dollars for
everybody
see this you're you're my type of people
a hundred percent like i
literally would go in there and here's
the trick let me tell you how i love to
eat my bottom meat so
i go in there they they always call me
hero because i give him a five dollar
tip oh as soon as i go in i walk to the
counter give him a five dollar tip and
me and there's like four little tiny
ladies that are just banging out these
sandwiches just like a freaking
steamroller
and i always go there give them the five
dollars i go up there and say i need
five number sixes which is the all
everything it's got the
jowl meat everything and like the the
head cheese and all this
absolutely everything and
and what i do is is just sit there
chill out listen to everybody it's a
little chitter chatter they're banging
out these sandwiches
for 15 they give you six of these
sandwiches they are
absolutely humongous down atlanta
downtown atlanta
they're like nine dollars and they're
not even half as good
i like to take those sandwiches and put
them in my refrigerator for like
three or four days all right i want
everything to kind of get everybody in
the pool together and just kind of
congeal in then i take a wet paper towel
wrap it in around the parchment paper
that they're in
and put it in the oven at like 325. it
steams the outside of that and heats it
completely up
where the outside has this nice little
crunch and it goes into the soft
a little bit of spicy sriracha mayo on
the inside and i swear
that sandwich is the crunch of the
daikon
everything that works after it's been in
the refrigerator all the flavors are
perfectly meld or just
it's one of the finest three dollar
items and that's six sandwiches you're
like at two dollars and sixty cents a
sandwich which i don't know any places
you can get a good sandwich for 250.
i mean it's one of those things it's
like like bunny sandwiches too
you know became hyper popular i guess
recently right which is great like i i
appreciate it a lot
uh it's weird though when uh there's a
lot of these mom and pop stores that
people don't really know about and
they've been doing like
bunnies forever and they don't get their
bread [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] bakery first
100 percent
yeah that's 100 percent this is a bakery
that is mon quinn's
is what it's called literally make their
bakery right in the next literally right
next door
in that and it's the section so where
we're at right now literally like
three miles away from here it's like my
favorite bun me spot and they do two
separate ones they do the typical
you know vietnamese french baguette and
they actually have a shorter stubbier
one which a lot of people don't do
and that's my favorite and i always
double up on the pate yeah so i love
vietnamese pate's the [ __ ]
yes it's so delicious it's delicious and
that's like the thing that people don't
see a lot because i know
uh you want that oily greasy smeller you
want all that deliciousness on there
and then sometimes you get a flat top
and they toast it with the pate
oh gosh there's like there's this weird
like sometimes i always have like this
aversion towards like certain like uh
like fusion food right because i feel
like sometimes people don't do it very
well
right you know like for example like
everybody started wrapping things in a
tortilla and it doesn't make it fusion
food right because vietnamese food is
technically fusion food like a bun me
that's french influence pate
you just nailed something and i want to
really talk about that
i think the word fusion has been a
bastard
bastardized word i think and what you
just
stated about a bond meat i believe a
bond meat is the
ultimate fusion dish and people toss
around fusion too much where it's
forced yeah you can't have force fusion
that's fraud
okay all right forced fusion equals
fraud
something that is a natural progression
of
well we got a lot of french people
around here making bread well we've got
a lot of this together what if we put
a to b together and let's see what
happens and it just
goes that i i think that a bond me is
like one of the greatest
fusions of all time it it it's something
that came together
out of necessity and it's flawless and
it just it's
i could eat them like a wood chipper
like you could line them up and it's
just
i mean just it's one of my favorite
things on the planet
you'll see that a lot with like like
peruvian food is one of my favorite
right
because you see first of all they use
soy sauce and everything the chinese
influence in peruvian food is highly
prevalent when you have lomo saltado
right like they even have their version
of their uh
like the chop the fried rice right right
and you you can see that
and almost like when you eat it it
sounds it tastes like a distinct dish it
doesn't seem like it stemmed from
something else
and i think that's that's the key when
you create fusion food when you eat it
and it has its own identity
absolutely right so you know when a lot
of these restaurants were opening up and
you know i think
because people were trying to catch on a
food wave which
by the way i personally think it's not
if you ever open up a restaurant if
you're catching up on a food way your
restaurant's going to disappear in three
years a grade
800 no questions all the time like i've
seen restaurants
in los angeles that i went to for sure
i'm sure
they had four and a half stars but they
but their food was very
you know wacky or whatever two years
they're gone they still had
a thousand reviews but if you baste your
food on a craze right
it's not going to last people get tired
of that stuff a lot of the restaurants
probably that you and i like right
are based off of a restaurant that has
one amazing dish
and they [ __ ] smash at it i need my
buddy my
buddy this is i cannot like that we
don't even really need to talk anymore
about the podcast now that i know i can
trust you with my life after stating
that i cannot explain
the amount of times that i explain to
people
about how when i say i'm going to open
my restaurant that i might have
three main courses maybe an appetizer
two
appetizers maybe two or three desserts
and you're gonna think it's the greatest
restaurant ever because yeah i'm going
to smash
the [ __ ] out of every one of those it's
going to be like a moab
of big bold beautiful flavors dropping
every time
what the [ __ ] do i go and anyone else
that they don't think about the
analytics it's like
you go to this place just because they
have really good fries you go to this
place just because this and people don't
think about that it's like
when you go to like a big chain
restaurant they're like oh i need a
cheesecake factory the [ __ ] out of it
and get like a damn
novel of a menu and you're just like
freaking marco polo here with the map
just like what the hell is going on here
we're going over here to
this place and it's like i'm in the
restaurant business i know what you have
to do to be able to freaking have this
kind of stuff and you can't keep all
this stuff fresh like it's not good
instead i'm going to sit here and be
like uh with the special tonight we're
going to be doing a
uh a joel rubicon butterwood potato with
this butter crusted
uh hard seared fillet uh with a board of
lays
it's going to be awesome it's going to
be great what else do you have that it's
going to be that
if you want something else have a good
day but that's going to be the best dish
ever
instead of 35 different things that are
half-assed
you'll see some of these restaurants in
l.a and you know back in the day when
these restaurants were opening up i
think a lot of people
specifically immigrants they opened up
these restaurants out of survival right
this is stuff that we have it's not here
so i'm gonna try to adapt certain foods
to whatever people like
that's why you have like i'll i could
even drive you just six miles from here
and i'll show you a burrito chinese
sushi shop
yeah you know but they've been open for
like 20 20 years and the reason why
they're still open is because it's just
a neighborhood staple
well sometimes when people open up these
new restaurants they're so afraid to
create a menu that doesn't have what
other people have they don't focus on
their menu
it's like don't worry about what's in
somebody else's pockets figure out what
you're good at
you know yes and so like you said
cheesecake factory is the best example
it is open it
what the [ __ ] is going on it looks like
the beginning of the bible
like what the [ __ ] is like do it yes
literally it's a great it's it's just as
smooth as a toolbox going downstairs
when you're reading it because you're
just like oh that sounds good this
sounds good
and here's the thing you screw yourself
you screw your business i don't want
people spending
18 years with the [ __ ] men you
order something for the love of god and
let's get rolling because now i can flip
this
like there was an interview there was an
interview in a
an um a uh investigation they hired
these pis this restaurant palms
restaurant
uh trying to figure out why the hell
they were losing money like they used to
they did a because
long story short they they got all the
tapes 10 years ago to
that year and figured out that the
difference and only difference that the
functioning and operating costs and
everything that was different is these
these people that were sitting down
would always be on their phones and
stuff and it's like there was an
additional like 13 to 15 minutes
of time it's like they started adding
this up of like when someone had a menu
instead of normally you would come in
there and i'd be your server and you'd
already be reading the menu because
you're not having your phone you're
looking at the menu
seeing what the hell they've got going
on then you'd be able to say okay i'll
have this this this now
people sit down they haven't even
thought about touching the menu they're
gonna wait around they're gonna shoot a
couple texts they're gonna do this this
this
if that does that three times that's 13
minutes that literally is one turn in
your night
if you do that on on literally 30 tables
you're literally losing your ass
just on the 13 minute to 15 minute flip
on a cell phone
so when i used to have this uh the soft
surf shop right
and love software it was like i planned
to open up another one uh
next year first one went down because of
we had some really bad business partners
and it was a whole ordeal i talked about
on this podcast we're not getting into
it but
one of the things that i was very uh
particular about we only had
four flavors one special right and those
four flavors
were you couldn't change the toppings
and people were like oh your service is
fast it's because well
we want you to have the software the way
we want it right
if you want gummy bears you want all
this other stuff this isn't the place
for you
like if i say this tastes like the
strawberry shortcake ice cream bar
from humor that i have created this is
how i'm going to serve it
if you want to add chocolate flakes or
whatever it's not going to happen
and it's not no disrespect to you it's
just this is what we're here for
correct you know and we can create that
fast because it's a certain experience i
want to give you
you know if you want to do it yourself
well there's other places where you
could walk in pour your own soft serve
put as much toppings as you want and
then you can walk out so for us it was
about turnaround
it's like you can get the soft serve
order what you want there's only four or
five flavors
you know right so if if i can give you
something
and this is what we learned i learned in
japan japan there is no
option of you taking [ __ ] out you can't
order something and say hey i don't want
ginger on it they would look at you like
get the [ __ ] out of my restaurant
there isn't any of this it's the omakase
thing you need to trust the chef
right and that's why in japan when you
go to a mcdonald's
you order the food it comes out in five
seconds
there isn't can i take out the pickles
can i take out the ketchup can i take
out the mustard is what it
it is exactly what it is that's what i
do
you you're hitting a great point on that
it's like the thing that i tell people
i'm exceptional is my
palate being able to taste salt balance
with fat and acid and i have an
exceptional pound because i've tried to
educate myself for so long
it's like i served someone the other
night and
before they before they even have tried
the steak with the sauce with potatoes
and all this stuff
they take one by the potatoes and they
start putting like freaking
crap garbage you know garlic salt
on the stuff like all over it it's like
i wanted to grab that plate and throw it
against the wall because like
i spend so much time making it taste
exactly
how i wanted it to taste to you like
it's balanced and i'm not one of those
pretentious like oh i just need
well done steak i'm gonna hammer like if
you don't wash done steak i can cook you
a juicy well done steak
but like when people like oh well
different
people's palettes are different and this
is like well no you didn't even you
didn't even execute what you're supposed
to do you
you tried a little little potatoes we
got this nice salted steak that's going
to be having the carrying the potatoes
through i can't boy that one that one
for me when you have people that just
when people just try to get difficult
like they're just like hey listen when
you're like i'm gonna i need
the special is this this this well can
you have the no onions on it's like well
the onions are in the sauce well yeah
but can you take those out
yeah it's like no that's that then it'll
throw everything
off it's like okay so we like the second
story of the house but the third story
is no good but the first story if we
could level that off it's like no you
can't
take the first story out because then
the second's gonna fall on the farm like
that's how it is like when you're
building flavors you can't just take
something out
also too it's like my thing about like
foods and restaurants
is you have choices of places that you
can go that'll serve it however the way
you want
there are denny's there are ihops and
and that's perfectly fine
listen i [ __ ] with that [ __ ] all the
time like i'll eat i'm a waffle house
guy man yeah know what i'm saying
absolutely if you but if you go to a
specific chef in a restaurant right
they they take time to serve it a
certain way right right there's
that's why i love food with a lot of
story behind it because it allows people
to enjoy the food a little more
yeah you know and i've talked on this
podcast a little bit more about
i love yelp because it's it's great for
small businesses but at the same time
sometimes it's bad
because there are people who believe
that they're experts on food without
even talking to the chef without
without even knowing the ingredient or
anything else so it's like hey
how can you come in and tell somebody
like for example i have a matcha spot
right
and we decided to try to commercialize
matcha in the way that
people have it in japan so people have
this conception
that matcha is only you know you only
drink it through ceremonies so in japan
they put in [ __ ] kitkats and condoms
so this is how common it is right and we
wanted people to understand that so we
made it more fun
um add a lot of fruit flavors or
whatever right
we recently switched the name out uh
because of some legal issues so we
changed it to junebe
well there were a couple of reviews from
other people who have never been to
japan
who don't even know the farm that we own
like we we are really particular about
our matcha
and somebody wrote they changed their
review from a one star to a to a five
and they said that this new spot is so
much better than the last i was like we
just changed the name
it's the same thing but this person came
out it
and like i said you are who you are but
you wrote about it as if you're an
expert about something that you don't
know it's a frauds or people are so from
like the original point of what you were
stating
earlier is people think that they're all
experts and like the influencers stuff
like that and i
i'm sponsored with over 30 companies and
i don't get
i don't get charged or anything because
i establish a partnership and a
friendship and i have a symbiotic
relationship with them and there's no
deadlines because they're paying me so
much money it's like i'm going to take
your product i'm going to sell the hell
out of it and i'm going to freaking do
it really well and your roi is going to
be absurd
because people trust me if i tell them
it's a good product
they know i'm not going to take [ __ ]
and it's like my
my buddy zach who's dolly parton's
photographer
who is the man we're going to do a whole
video and i'm going to show about how
these
influencers how fraudulent how they
think they're so good at cooking food
all this stuff
and i'm going to show how we can take a
guy that has no idea how he's cooking
and i want to show how they can edit it
to make him look like he is an absolute
stud and knows everything about it
this podcast is brought to you by raycod
my friends if you have never used raycon
earbuds
you are not blessing your ears with the
sound of
wonderful music and podcasts listen
everywhere i go whether i'm traveling
whether i'm working out kickboxing
biking
i take my reikon earbuds why because the
sound quality is amazing and not only
that
they're super light and compact a lot of
these earbuds out there that are on this
market right now
are cool looking but they're so big the
case that they come in the charging case
specifically is huge
raycon earbuds are light and compact and
i
love them and on top of that they are
priced
competitively at half the price as other
major brands
that may or may not sound either just as
good or
probably even worse than raycon's i love
my earbuds listen
that's just what i'm saying from what
i'm using i'm no professional sound
engineer but i love raycon earbuds i
listen to music every day
and i have no regrets raycon's offering
15 off all their products for my
listeners and here's what you got to do
to go and get it go to buyrecon.com
buyrecon.combrain
and that's it you'll get 15 off your
entire raikon order so feel free to grab
a pair
and a spare that's 15 off at buy recon
dot com slash brain
that's by recon dot com slash brain
about how like
these some of these influencers will dye
water and call it a sauce and it's like
you don't know what it tastes like you
don't have a clue like
they can say anything about it and like
oh look it's perfectly plated and the
seasoning's off and all this all right
and so many people think they know
so much now more than ever like me it's
almost like an entitlement it's like an
entitlement like
look at me look at me i'm so great i
don't i don't understand it
it i think now humility people are
getting caught up in the feeling of
i want to be somebody who is an expert
at something then rather being an expert
right
because being an expert actually takes
time you're right impatience
it's impatience rights and impatience
and so like when i
right like for example um i was a judge
on on a food show called the best
leftovers ever right there were a lot of
great contestants
but there were a few that i felt that
they were uh instagram chefs too in the
worst type of way sometimes
right great people i love them right but
i find this a lot even with some of my
friends who who cook for me i'm not an
amazing chef but i stick to what i know
right and one of the best advice that i
got from um
a buddy of mine uh chef matt ewan he
goes addition by subtraction and do what
you know very well
understand the foundation and then you
can build on top of it love that so
uh you know we had some people coming in
they were like i'm going to do this dish
with the coddled egg and
i'm like do you know how to cook a
cuddled egg right and then i got this
piece of [ __ ] you know right they they
saw a lot of these fun techniques
online and they tried to imitate it's
like well let's start with the first
thing do you know how to poach an egg
can you fry an egg properly can you
scramble and they probably
are my people you're my people don't
know you're hitting that you're you're
dude like you're
a hundred percent i'll never forget it
one of my one of my
good friends still today a mentor his
name is danny mellman
and i was in culinary school at the time
and he was running uh
restaurants in blue ridge where i was at
and he's like i don't [ __ ] understand
what y'all are what y'all are learning
up there
he's like he's like i got people that
can't even fry eggs that are trying to
make this compound
stupid freaking he's like start with the
basics he's like
what are the five mother sauces he's
like let's start there he goes
master those five mother sauces because
it'll take you a year or so to figure
out how to do those it goes
then you go on to the sub mother sauce
he's like take the best smell make a
morning because
work on that for a little while because
all y'all's generation always wants to
do
is just freaking have it made he's like
just like oh i'm gonna take this this
this this this and it's gonna magically
where it goes
that's not how this works she's like it
takes time patience
practice i've never not listened to that
i've always said that it's like
understanding how to keep it between the
ditches the mayonnaise the mustard like
understanding like it is okay to of
course
read something and i'm very good at like
show me a picture i can create this
but i have the humility to be like no
this [ __ ] this technique is some son of
a [ __ ] like this is
like way out of my wheelhouse i'm going
to need to work on this
before i'm able to present it because
i'm so i'm so
prideful in my cooking because i want to
make people so happy with my food like i
love telling a story with my food
like this is how we got here to here to
here to here to here now we got this
today cooking with h woo in them like i
was cooking
uh some delicious yucca triple fried
yucca
uh we got uh some fresh uh wasabi root
got the snake or the shark skin freaking
grate it
made a lemon caper wasabi aioli
dude it slapped it slat it salted me it
assaulted every person that ate it it
had everyone in the house coming out to
eat this
like just staring at each other being
like what is going on i was like i'm
associate like because
i'm i'm a wheelhouse sauces like you can
say i've got this protein i got this
vegetable i'll tell you like i can make
this sauce for this and it's gonna
this sauce today man like just absolute
just
punch you in the it's so good so
bouncing like
i i never messed with yooka until i
married my brazilian wife
so i saw her do it and then just started
building it in my head i was like
something so
simple but i was humble enough to be
like no i'm gonna watch you
even though i'm the the professional
chef and because i have no idea and as
soon as i tried my wife's uk
hers yooka is mine's freaking delicious
hers
is still substantially better her eucas
actually
yeah it's like it's like but people will
people be like
oh yeah i'm gonna make this and it's
like post this you're like
do you know how long the little my
grandma
has been doing this for freaking literal
60 years that that's nothing like she
makes
it's like gordon ramsay did one it was
one of the funniest one he did pad thai
he didn't pay bro he did
[ __ ] i was like are you kidding me like
gordon's like no one's ever said
something like this
like it's good it's not pad thai at all
that pad thai video
hilarious dying because the face that he
made at him he goes what do you think he
goes
yeah yeah he's like this isn't bad like
this is
this is like and that that was one of
those things of gordon me like you know
what i'm a really good chef i should be
able to just do this
it's like no this guy like knows like
how to build this
ladder of flavor up that you need to
either you've got to go
down the road like you had to travel the
road to know where the stop signs are
like you can't just be like
up here on the view like well it looks
like it's pretty good up here no
that's not how it works and it's just
like like also too
i think the reason why i i also
sometimes dislike a lot of like food
content and i've
i know people who do this it's like they
they learn this recipe from like i don't
know bon appetit or something right and
they
recreate it on their on their tick tock
or whatever and they tell people that
this is how it's made
it's like well first of all we we talk
about repetition repetition is
everything right
also too it's like for example i've
eaten ethiopian food maybe five or six
times
your bread yeah i can't really create
the food because i haven't made it i
haven't eaten it enough
i don't know what's in it yet incorrect
you know what i mean but if you give me
a korean dish i've grown up with it and
this is what i found out when i started
cooking myself at home was
there's a reason why i couldn't cook
italian food well i didn't grow up
eating it a lot all right but there's a
reason we're going to the nuances
exactly you've not traveled the [ __ ]
road how the [ __ ] are you supposed to
know where everything's located if
you're not from the village
exactly so like when i started cooking
korean food i'm like my korean food is
substantially better
because i've developed 30 years of a
palette with food so i understand what i
can taste for what i can't
and so when uh sometimes too people
always focus on a lot of the aesthetics
which i agree you eat with your eyes
first i understand that concept however
it still has to taste good again 100
[ __ ] tastes good well you mean they
say you eat with your eyes first and
stuff it's like
a lot of times like i use my hands
because
whenever you're getting the senses like
whenever you have a fork you're taking
it away like you can smell it you can
look you can just
you need to feel it like your body
reacts when you pick up things that's
what's changed a lot of my food like i
ate
exponentially more food with my hands
when i went to india it kind of changed
the whole thing but before then
i still ate with my hands yeah getting
your senses getting things rolling
it's like you're getting a muscle memory
to the food you're getting a
relationship
closer you're literally swaddling up
literally the food
but i look at it as like how you said
the korean thing is like
i look at it as literally like your
communal village like i
literally have eaten in this place so
long i know all the back roads i know
where everything is i know what i need
to see
when you drop off at a place that your
palate's uneducated in
it's literally like you're a tourist so
you don't know what's good you don't
know where you're going with it you
don't know what's right what's wrong
like
oh i think this is delicious like
gordon's the prime example
it probably tasted good as hell like it
probably was delicious
not bad time yeah because it's like you
didn't put this two or three things in
that anybody that's done this for 30
years would know oh you should have put
the fish paste in here
this should have put this in there
that's the prime example and so many
people want like instant gratification
and it's like
i don't understand why people try to do
other things that other people are doing
which is a big trend now and just like
like the food
trends and stuff and it's like why don't
what happened to the classics
like what happened to the [ __ ] that
we've been like when you go to india and
people have been eating this food for 5
000 years
it's like you don't mess with there was
a there was a uh
dino or gino the thing that uh gordon
ramsay geno and the frenchman there's
like three of them that go traveling
around gino's an italian guy i think his
name is gino
uh or dino i think his name is dadgum
dean i can't remember
yeah some italian guy he was on a
cooking show a british cooking show
and this woman starts talking about how
she puts mushrooms and sour cream in
this
in this dish which this clearly was like
bolognese or something
she's like i just love to do this this
is like why and he just he just starts
freaking out and going an italian
rant he's like this is what's wrong with
this freaking country
yeah he's like this is what's wrong with
it he's like you have a dish we've been
doing so long and goes in and so i'm
going to change it he's like you just
want to change everything change
everything
it works it's a classic you don't have
to change it you don't need to put your
spin on it just
eat it the way that it's supposed to be
eating like whenever you're doing your
own thing it's like
oh look at these people that have been
doing this for thousands of years are
wrong
let's just do this and listen i i like
innovation but there's like certain
things difference though
with like italian food right for example
i i had carbonara for the longest time
right and
what i mean by for the longest time is a
lot of these pops that used uh cream and
bacon in it i was like oh this is good
and then i had real carbonara
with just the starch from the water the
egg parmesan cheese
sponge or sometimes like pursue whatever
they wanted right and i was like
this is a different experience and i
didn't understand why they changed it
decadence decadence of carbonard one of
my favorite dishes cream wasn't
necessary no
you didn't have to use bacon at all no
and you didn't have to add parsley you
didn't need any of this stuff and so
when i ate it i'm like
when i when i thought about that was why
right because
the original carbonart is also cheaper
to make than the one with the cream
so why was the cream added and so that's
that's where i understand where
that's not innovation you're just kind
of kind of [ __ ] that one up a little
bit 100
it's easier it's it's it's it that's
such an easy dish but when you add cream
cream
cream is such a foolproof thing when you
have fat on things
it makes things the emulsification is so
much easier so you put the cream in
there
and you can just put the cream flip
around the egg you can bust it yeah
exactly so that would be my guess as
they put the cream in there to freaking
just stabilize it absolutely
i remember just like when i would watch
all these videos there's this guy's
his youtube is called vincenzo's plate
and um italian chef and he just
critiques
uh other major chefs who make italian
food right and to me it's just hilarious
it's just [ __ ] funny because of how
he freaks out right so he also critiqued
um
gordon ramsay's carbonara really he
added cream
and peas and bacon and he was like what
the [ __ ]
right this is not even close this is
some freaking
alanola like what is this
just watching him watching his italian
spirit break
made me die laughing his italian spirit
breaks
his heart just crumbles it was just
[ __ ] like shattering
as he watched somebody bastardize one of
his favorite dishes
and i think what i really liked about
italian food when i was trying to
uh learn how to cook some stuff here and
there i buy a lot of like chef books and
i follow other people
was just um understanding how simple it
was there was there's not
a lot of a variation in the ingredients
it's very simple but it's high quality
[ __ ]
so like just the difference between
canned tomatoes and then san marzano
tomatoes
uh yes and then you have to defend then
you have to see the difference between
real san marzano and fake san marzano
tomatoes she's like
if you get real san marzano on the
hillside there's a ginormous difference
in flavor
it's crazy how much more sweeter they
are yes right and it's not like me just
saying
you could faintly taste it it tastes
substantially essentially better
yeah it's like having really parmesan
reggiano and instead of literally having
parmesan
yeah it's like there's a difference here
like it has to be from that region or
it's no good and it's got to be stamped
and pressed but
no i uh i'm right there with you man
like on all the food on all like the the
the italians i have a great friend
uh helena been friends with her for
years she's probably the most talented
pizza
pizza torah on the planet um
she did a pizza class with me last week
and
we only had like four ingredients making
this nepalese
uh pizza dough i'm thinking like this is
it like this
stuff that you're making is four
ingredients like what the hell i thought
there was going to be this and this and
this and this
there's four ingredients and i'm like my
god like the italians just like this is
simple stuff
and it's just done right it see it it's
like literally the
the ultimate kiss mentality keep it
simple stupid
yeah yeah it is that cooking like and
like going to india
you have this food that is so
simple yet so complex like it's like
there's 13 different spices in here and
it's like it was
the simplicity these people don't think
a thing about it but like if you tried
to jump in on that
it would be an absolute train wreck like
they're like oh it's this this this this
this
just like one of this one or this one or
this one it's like oh it's a simple
ingredient it's like yeah but there's
like 45
like what the heck indian food is so
much about layering too
italian is no layering i don't taste
italian food
as a layering kind of food like i don't
ever
eat and like man the layering here is
just substantial there's like
there's the heat and then there's the
cream like if i get like a good
you know a good diablo sauce or
something like that some kind of a nice
spicy sauce
then i start to kind of get a layering
but for me italian food is not
is not a super layering type of food
like if you have some like ridiculous
some
incredible korean food some incredible
chinese food some incredible
there's so many different textural
levels and we're all over the place you
can have like
cold writing over here and then you're
going over to this soft fluffy like
the textures are back italians like
i know it's coming at me like i can
stare at this and my eyes can
immediately tell me
what happens it's not an adventure for
me like when i'm when i'm looking at
some korean stuff
i'm like koreans my gosh like they they
eat
everything like it is it is such a
respect to
everything kind of cult indian chinese
same thing so it's like
it's such an adventure like eating this
little thing oh this is a tripe stew i'm
going to eat this kind of texture on
this
attack you go in huh yeah absolutely
absolutely so for me
for me italian food love italian food
one of my favorite things i love the
elegance of how simple it is
but it's such it's one of those things
that is so different than like what i
love to eat i love adventurous cooking
like
northern thai food is so fun for me
because
have you been to thailand no because of
that because like the the nice
lime like the citrus in it and you get
that tang
and the pop and the crunch they're just
how long are you here for i gotta go
tomorrow at 10 o'clock
okay the whole reason i'm out here is
literally to do this podcast
in the drive that's it that's literally
the only reason i'm here 10 o'clock what
night time
and height okay i got to take you to
uh we got to go to thai town there's a
couple of spots that i really really
[ __ ] enjoy
it's pa or noodle they specific they
specialize specifically only in like
noodle soups
they also they have a few other stuff
right oh boy you know what i mean like
uh and there's also this
spot next to it called a pork belly gang
but it's thai
as [ __ ] right i love it thai food i love
it here's the thing about
food right like when i had thai food out
in sacramento right there's a lot of
thai spots but they're
very americanized thai and then you go
to thai town and this is a completely
different experience
they don't really hold back for the
american palette
this is thai food like i had it right
it's going to smack you in the [ __ ]
face right absolutely we're going to
take you salty we're going to go swish
we're going to go sour we're going to go
save
mommy just yeah and this is where it's
going to be absolutely absolutely that's
what i want i literally get
i want to get assaulted when i eat the
food like i want i want i want like
ninjas of flavor coming at me and like
hitting me in the face that's what i
want thai food like thai is something
that i literally
get excited for impact like yeah i want
good
there's a restaurant here's the thing
there's a great restaurant in new york
it's a one michelin star it's called
some tom
okay uh and we all
all the master chef me and my buddies
the master buds
nick sherry evan sam suba
um we went there and it was like 55
i mean i ate my ass off i ate my ass off
it was only like 55
bucks a person i was like we've been
eating for an hour and a half here like
i just
what it's only 55. i only owe you 55
bucks yeah it's literally like 300 and
something dollars for the 60s and like
i'm talking it's a michelin star
i'm talking everything i could eat i
mean pitching like nolan ryan
just howitzer and i could not get the
bill that high and it was the most
delicious
fresh so fresh so fresh this is why like
rest in peace
rest in peace like john jonathan gold
like he really
shed a lot of light onto these mom and
pop stores right
because the michelin star was given to a
lot of these restaurants that did you
know
molecular gastronomy they had all this
but they was like hold on a second what
about these restaurants right here
these mom-and-pop places because i
guarantee you you guys wouldn't be able
to replicate their food
right i agree and so he started giving
it to these taco trucks
his jonathan gold star and it it really
allowed people to see how great food can
be outside of the setting that you're
sitting in
right because food is like because you
haven't even gone out to east la to
these tacos trucks right like this
like you it would be impossible to eat
your way through la it's
like in a matter of like well that's
what i told you that's what i said
beaufort farmer's market
we got two miles of hell like you are i
mean
i've got two miles you have rhode island
you have rhode island you have the whole
state of rhode island like the size of
rhode island is your food
place like it's absurd the amount of
different the variety
of food that you have when you're here
so like when people come here too
like a lot of my friends who are out of
town there's a lot of restaurants that
people want to try but i i can never
recommend them
the uh the i call them like the uh the
west hollywood restaurants
right because i i've eaten there before
and they're really good but i
like looking for like the the hole in
the wall that's right
that's me so you know that's the
restaurants that i want to show them
like my buddy vince and i we literally
did like taco crawls every [ __ ] week
for a year
just for fun that sounds fantastic that
sounds fantastic you know
gurney coral i would need a gurney after
that
wheel me around i had a friend i have a
friend her name is out in new york and
whenever she comes here i'm like well
let's take you on that taco crawl and i
take her to my favorite spots in east
l.a
and it's it's hard to replicate that
right they there's this place called uh
tacos ibiri la unica and they do birya
tacos
which is you know students i cook the
[ __ ] out of some
tacos i make some ridiculous ones some
stupid good ones goat
i regular goat so you go to like ibi la
unica and then right around the corner
is mariscos jalisco they do these shrimp
tacos dorados
right and then then at 5 pm at night
you'll go to the alca bon tacos
my mom's texting i'm the half texans the
tacos have been a big part of my life
like oh yeah i've been eating the amount
of tacos that i forget
we have a spot that god only god thank
you
thank you god for this that we have this
mexican spot it's lowe's dose hermanus
and uh
all women a hundred percent ran by women
little grocery store and my town is like
20
000 people in the county in the town
there's 1500 in my little town is 500
like there's not
any good really good ethnic restaurants
at all the chinese restaurant joke but
this
restaurant makes like the best
most authentic mexican food that you can
get i mean like i'm very i'm a stickler
for real authentic
but we're talking it can't get more
authentic we're talking
we're talking a dollar twenty-five
little tacos
we're talking esquite elote world-class
enchiladas
homemade sauces and it's cheap you can
get a cup of
esquite for two dollars oh [ __ ] you can
get a tostada for two dollars and the
tostada is this big
it is the best deal in town i tell
everyone if anyone asks me because i get
asked all the time
where do i eat that's right two dollar
tostada
chorizo bean cheese guacamole three
slice of avocado
two dollars like a wood yeah
i mean dude all day they are so nice
they are so
kind i tipped them a hundred percent
it's one of the few restaurants that i
took 100 percent
like if my bill is dollars it's forty
dollars yeah i just give the [ __ ] out of
money to them cause i'm like please
god just stay open because i've been
here my whole life and this just sucks
and like i
if i want good food i gotta cook it and
i love cooking
but it's like i love that me and my dad
my dad just retired uh in december i
love that my dad like hey let's go get
some lunch and i can go to a spot
but i'm gonna i'm getting treated like
family they love me
they they give me they give me food
instantly like it's like a magic show
it's like david copperfield trick
without the touching but i mean
it's it's i am a like with tacos man
like i could beat kobayashi on like five
five down like get five down five down
quickly like just i
just gone i'm gonna take you to a taco
crawl we're gonna go
like straight up we'll do like my
favorite fish taco spots
right we'll definitely get dessert at uh
one of my favorite like churro spots
a i'm a sugar addict so i can definitely
do this like
those are a little different you know
what i mean the [ __ ] out of them you
know because like typically when you
have a churro right like it's crispy on
the outside you have the cinnamon
cinnamon and sugar that's great but
jadisko trudeau is a little different in
the sense that they're a little
um creamy on the inside still it's a
little different
and it's my favorite that sounds
delicious right and they had their uh
goat's milk caramel on top of it
it's different dude so when you're all
in for that yeah uh yes and then we'll
go to marico's jalisco they have their
tacos dorados
right there they have their agua chile
it's super [ __ ] good
spicy as [ __ ] really good though what
about
indian people what about indian food in
la is there any of that there is i mean
there's
anything like that because i'm like
we've i've gone to little tokyo i went
to a little korea town i went but like
it hit me i was like there's i've not
seen any indian
there there is but they're in like
different pockets there's like indians
and
indian and nepalese yes right so there's
a there's a few spots pockets are just
not just
not big here i could show you my
favorite spot it's literally a market
yeah yeah it's so delicious
good it did i don't understa it's very
simple for me i'm like why i think truly
indian food is the best food on plan is
like they've literally been done
doing it longer than anybody they've
literally been cooking longer i'll tell
people this too
like i i've said this before if i ever
wanted to become vegetarian i'm eating
indian food
no question because they don't ever be
they say they say non-meat in india they
say non-meat is what they say it's like
you want non-meat like yeah i'm taking
on me
i mean i'm i'm a plant-based guy that
changed i was a carnivore to plant-based
but like when i'm on vacation and i want
to eat good food i want to eat something
so
but i do plant-based because i just feel
exponentially better that's the thing
that people always kind of mess up on is
like
i choose to do it because my my you feel
like
i'm a war machine with it like dude i
can the
the fluidity of thought process my
anxiety i suffer from immense depression
immense
anxiety and you never know unless i said
it
because i just battled through it but
one of the best things i've ever done on
treatment-wise was literally doing
plant-based like i
didn't feel like i wanted to jump off a
bridge every day being on plant-based
it's like when i went full meat
get terrible thoughts and it's like i'm
a guy that wouldn't want it like i've
done all this diets all this stuff
plant-based was something that when i do
it like i just feel
so much better but i still love like
getting some mozzarella frying it up
like just some little here and there
like an ice cream scoop you know
but i know that i'm going to pay the
piper because of it i know that i'm
going to feel excellent yeah dude if i
eat a bowl of cereal
and i've been plant-based for sure and
as soon as i eat a bowl of cereal it is
it literally feels like i'm having
a demon eat my stomach it just yeah
insulin like dairy
hurts so before you went plant blaze how
long were you dealing with like these
thoughts and emotions was like
depression and
oh dude i've had i've had i've had i've
had mental
health issues since i was like since i
was a kid i was molested when i was five
i didn't tell anybody
until i was like 27 years old and like
just kind of
built this this i don't know this what i
was i
the man that i am it was because of what
happened and the way i kind of
did like night in shining arm always
watching over people not letting anyone
ever mess with anybody it's like what
if i see anybody messing with anybody
else i'm going to step in
if i see a woman getting touched by a
man we have a problem like
and like i had so many
so much anger so much pain i turned to
sugar so i was always addicted to sugar
i got up to like 360 pounds
um i never was a victim never told
anybody never said this is why i'm
feeling this way
this is why this i just kept to myself
even though like
every day knowing how blessed i was
knowing how good my life was
still having like well the world would
be better if you jump
off this bridge like this the world
would be better if you got off and being
like having to fight yourself
every single day for no reason
and having to deal with that every day
um
and not giving it to anybody else so for
me
and having the anxiety that i had
got to the point of just being like
enough's enough like i'm
crippled like so i've got to do
something different like i've got to try
something else
so when i went plant-based i did it when
i was in the bahamas
uh when everyone was just it was such a
mess
after dorian it was just a literal war
zone i was like you know what this is a
great freaking time i've got tons of
vegetables
cans of beans i was like this is a great
time so i went plant-based
uh for two weeks it was so hard but then
all of a sudden i just started getting
everything in my life aspect wise
just stamina endurance vascularity
mental clarity reflexes i had one time
something
fell out of the truck the scepter truck
so do septic i remember i flipped my arm
behind my back and caught it without
even looking and like
just my body reacted and driving and
everything
i started doing the research and trying
to figure it out it made perfect sense
it's like
having the animal fats and animal
proteins in your body
just think of it just as a as a as a
slowing down
process of your blood your fluidity your
neurological
bridge ways are slowed down and
congested with animal fats so when you
don't have those animal fats
the fluidity of neurons everything goes
much better
which is i i did a whole thesis 13 years
ago on
cbds and how they cured cancer and all
this even though i was a loon
boy was i freaking right about
everything that's happened about thc and
legalization i was going to be a billion
dollar industry and all that
doing stacking plant base while stacking
with thc and cbd
have made me where at 34 years old
i am in the best shape of my life and
within i'm about 15 pounds away from my
total goal of where i want to be
and it's like the the key to what i'm
speaking on is
you cannot fix the outside machine if
you don't have the inside machine
working i had to fix my brain first
before i tried to fix my body
and i always tried to just work on my
body and just failed losing weight
failed losing weight failed
i constantly [ __ ] like idiot like god
[ __ ] [ __ ] like
i do this this this this i get so
[ __ ] close
and then i just fail it's like [ __ ] so
that stacks it back on so instead
this time i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna
rewrite my computer i'm gonna get my
programming i still recognize how
how i'm so blessed but i'm gonna work on
my mental health and once i got my
mental health
everything else has fallen into place
everything else in my body had fallen in
place so now
that i've got my brain right i'm able to
start moving forward
i still struggle every day with immense
anxiety but you have a choice either
you're going to let it affect you
or you're going to [ __ ] do your best
it's like yeah all i can do is my best
like because sometimes you don't want to
get out of bed
sometimes you're just like god [ __ ] like
a heart attack
like i've been trying to tell people
this so i mean this is the hard part
with this conversation when people hear
stuff like this right because
i i lost uh 70 pounds so
uh i just counted my calories that's all
i did i was like okay
i'm just gonna stop eating so much all
right i just pulled back put this put
the hamburger down put the hamburger
down
like did you have to eight thousand
calories
probably not probably not so like you
know and a big part of it probably was
because of the anxiety issues that i had
right
and you you hit on a point that i think
a lot of people don't want to hear
because they have this defeatist
mentality right it's
when i tell people i have anxiety people
think oh you don't have my anxiety i was
like listen
i have anxiety to the point by the way
i'm gonna share this right now
i didn't renew my [ __ ] dmv my license
for a [ __ ] year
because i was too anxious to go inside
the dmv because it was freaking me out
i just renewed it last week after a year
that happens you know and so when i tell
people i have anxiety i do
the the difference between me and you is
that i try to
face it head on you know the the the
license thing just happened to work well
pandemic because i wasn't driving
anymore so i'm like [ __ ] it right
but i do stand up and i deal with
anxiety all the time
and i keep telling people that you have
this you have an option and that's the
beautiful thing right
maybe not so depression also too i don't
like i haven't felt depression before
but
anxiety crippling anxiety has been
something that i have to deal with on a
daily
and it's something that i have to learn
how to face right
because i can sit in my room and just
wallow in self-defeat
or i could say i have this issue but i
have to face it if not then i can't do
anything about it
absolutely i think nowadays with a lot
of people
they just want to pinpoint what's wrong
with them and just accept it you can't
accept it
agreed 100 that's what i'm saying you
can you've got to keep moving forward
what you said about the dmv hit
hit home with me because like like a
bill i always pay my bills got
incredible credit and stuff
but there's some times there's like like
pay your bill no it's like no i don't
want to it's like pay your bill no it's
like what the [ __ ] is going on here like
i'm go
i need to pay this bill like i know
exactly what you're talking about
just pay the goddamn bill no like i'm
like no i'm not doing this
like i have it nope i'm not doing it not
doing it at all
like yeah like going to the dmv is like
just go to the [ __ ] dmv like
why won't you like i know i need to go
and you're like having this conversation
with yourself like
i'm not insane like move your
ass i've been there so many times
what's bad is when that happens and then
you're just like okay with it like you
said just settle with like okay well
pinpointed here there it is
like no you need to evolve you need to
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on why
is this causing this to move on what the
problem is
with anxiety stacked on depression is is
that you get into this
paradox where you just can't [ __ ]
move like it is like
the anxiety sinks you and then the
depression just
tombstones you it's like you just get
stacked on stacked on stacks so for me
having depression
like anxiety was something that i could
start to see
coming on like i could see it starting
to build its thing up
depression would just be making no
sense depression for me never like and
like for me depression makes no [ __ ]
sense when you analyze that you're so
blessed and that everything is good
but anxiety still like it is sort of a
[ __ ]
like that's something that's like no
logic like they're it just it just
starts building up you're like i'm good
i'm god still just
keeps going and depression just has i
feel like depression is just this thing
that's just power bombs and like you
just can't see it coming and it just
drops on you and no matter why you can't
figure
ever out the why like it that's what i
think the biggest thing about why
suicide is so high is that you can't
figure out and get to the core
problem of what the [ __ ] is going on
with depression anxiety
you can see kind of what the [ __ ] is
going on here like
why am i getting upset about going to
the dmv this is not a [ __ ] big deal
this is a blessing that i can get in my
car
drive to the dmv make my life easier
by having this this license on time so
it's not
expired why can't you do that
things you're like anxiety okay good
depression there would be no
people you're just getting double [ __ ]
you don't know what the [ __ ]
like i mean so for me it's like being
open and honest being a giant six foot
seven
white guy that never had anybody [ __ ]
with them on being a racist or anything
like that
i looked at it as my job of being open
and honest about it
and showing my power is showing
empathy i'm able to feel people's energy
and be able to take their
pain and be able to pile it on my
shoulders and be able to open them up to
a different way that they're like
why am i able to talk to this guy about
this because i give a [ __ ]
i actually care i'm not i'm not asking
you a question unless i really want to
know
what's going on with you like tell me
what's popping and i've seen that that's
helped people so much with anxiety
because
it slows the process down of like what
the [ __ ] is happening
it's like why are you freaking out well
i just i got this this is
okay well let's break down the rest of
the day you got eight hours
so you got eight hours how long do you
think that'll take well three okay well
listen you can either
freak out right now for three hours or
whatever not get it done
and then you're gonna be you know
whatever just in the same spot with five
hours left in the day or
you can hammer this out the rest of the
day is just
copacetic everybody's fine
everything's done and you move on i said
this is so easy like let's just break
this down you get it done you know you
got to get it done
or you literally still got to get it
done
and you feel like [ __ ] because you just
keep procrastinating and not get your
head out of your ass
like you know what's interesting too
like i what i started finding out when i
was having conversations with people who
were dealing with anxiety was
i found that there's two types of people
there's people who identify their
anxiety and they use it as a crutch
or there's the second person who
identifies and it's like now i know how
to fix this correct
and so i the first time i realized i had
anxiety because i just never knew what
this [ __ ] was
i just kind of considered i'm just a
[ __ ] that's how i would talk to myself
decade i felt like that's like like why
am i crying
like what the [ __ ] is i'm not pregnant
like
is happening here trust me yes yeah and
so it was just
little quick moment that i had with my
fiance and we moved into this apartment
out in glendale
and i think you and i had the same
person i'm not sure if you feel this way
but
we tend to want to learn every in and
out about something
because of our anxiety 100 likes because
i don't want to not know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking i don't want surprises i
don't want surprises ever i want to be
able to open my mouth and it's going let
it rip
exactly so my friend they realized it
too they were like we were walking
around and we're walking around south
pasadena and i'm telling them all this
information about the air like why do
you know this [ __ ] and i was like it's
because of my anxiety
like i feel like i have to be
knowledgeable about [ __ ] in case of
conversation or whatever the [ __ ] that
it is
do you have fallout do you have fallout
plans about pretty much
like like a billion different situations
i will tell
i will like if this happens this is what
we're gonna be doing we're gonna go this
this this this this this like no we're
on a plane it's like yeah well listen
if a [ __ ] terrorist is on the right
side of the [ __ ] plane in the front
part of this
this is what you need to do you need to
go to the far back right bathroom like
always have some people think it's chris
like we have nothing better to do
except to try to live a functional life
and if we think there's a probability
that that could be
ended let's just have a plan and just
you know
circle navigate that a little bit that's
how it is it's like
having like why not having getting you
know a speeding ticket i think like if i
was a cop where the hell would the cop
be it's like
it gives me anxiety thinking that i'm
driving really fast and there's a cop
here what do i do i think about if i was
a cop where would i be
i don't get speeding tickets it's like
it's the overthinking thing
yes and the crazy thing i'm peace in
that it's like my adhd brain by working
in the overdrive i get actually more
peace
than if it just calmed down and didn't
think about anything you know what's so
funny because like
i was telling you so when i was with my
fiance and glendale it's when we moved
in
and i didn't plan out by measuring out
the space between the cabinetry and some
of my equipment stuff if it would fit in
the room
and i didn't do that ahead of time and
so when we were trying to move it in
i started freaking the [ __ ] out i
started getting angry i was cursing and
stuff she looked and she goes
what are you doing i'm like this is not
gonna [ __ ] work this is [ __ ]
and she's like what hold hold on for a
second we're gonna walk outside let's
take a breath it's like no this shit's
not gonna [ __ ] work this is stupid
and i was like
she's looking she goes i don't
understand you're a man of the same dude
i'm like wait hold on what is this and i
was like oh
i think i have anxiety issues i've been
dealing with this [ __ ] my whole life
and then she was the point of the one
that pointed out how it doesn't make
sense like this is weird
but then on the flip side a bit on some
[ __ ] really strong
challenging [ __ ] that other people are
losing your [ __ ] you're looking at them
like what the [ __ ] you like just become
right
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
this is easy like what is going on here
but then on this thing
you're like not the cool not this alpha
you're going bait i do the same thing
like
ben i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
like get you this is nothing
like this is nothing you're freaking out
over nothing and my wife does the same
things like no calm down like
no this is the end of the world she's
like
that no it's not what are you what are
you what are you yelling for
god sorry the [ __ ] says is this this
this like
no it's not what am i doing calm down
it's like that mentality of certain
things that we accept and choose not to
accept right so
one of the things is like i tend to for
some reason no matter what car i'm in
somebody [ __ ] hits me
but because i've accepted the reality
that somebody's going to hit me
i i'm always cool about [ __ ] great i'm
like it's whatever so
we'll go through this this and this i
know how to deal with this situation is
fine
but then i can't fit a cabinet into a
room and i'm freaking the [ __ ] out
it's like it doesn't make sense it
doesn't but i've been able
because i've been able to recognize what
it is now when i have the episode i can
be like in the middle
of it say hey you're being unreasonable
this is an anxiety attack
take a step outside relax you know and i
think if i didn't do that i wouldn't
have
been able to do it before because i just
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
my dad says that you got a good point my
dad is
one of the smartest people i've ever met
i'm sure everyone's like my dad
but my dad is really a special special
guy
and he's like
it doesn't cost you anything to just
stop and step back
the life is not not life is not in that
near second because you can make a
split-second decision that that will
cost you your life
he's like just step back doesn't cost
anything
just it does there's no reason like if
you feel like something like
stop reassess and move on he's like
you're brilliant use your brain like if
it doesn't make sense
stop pause a minute i i believe people
rush into things so quickly nowadays
because like we go back to the original
point of
not being patient at all and it's just
like
my anxiety my anxiety now i
am able to like step back a little bit
instead of like not being able to get
the cabinet or like
i [ __ ] cut this freaking thing
perfect and it doesn't fit and it's like
i measured it right
and then god forbid if somebody else is
brave enough to hop
in here to get into this [ __ ] show and
then they're giving me misinformation
that's making my life more difficult
now the [ __ ] exactly now we're just like
you are just
here we don't need to go to here we need
to go
here so like so for me
being being a person i think the key
really to
and i believe this wholeheartedly that
what has helped me the most with my
anxiety is self-awareness
having self-awareness on understanding
where i'm [ __ ] up
where am i where where where are my
cores that i'm going for
and then getting a game plan for those
they don't happen
i used to not have any analytics on i'd
have the plan of like if these are
things that happen
never have any analytics about getting
me mad like if this step
one's happening we need to go to this if
this is happening go to this
now i'm like kind of like i have a
checklist on how to get
not so hot not so analytically
[ __ ] on myself where i'm just throwing
all this stuff
energy all over the place just like a
fire hose all over the place
having controlled thought it's the idea
of taking responsibility right
the taking responsibility part is hard
for a lot of people it's hard for me too
but we have to because everything is
just out of our control
and then we get into the cycle of
blaming everybody else for our problems
that's
is that just society did you just say
that society that's society in a
nutshell i started going down like the
[ __ ] hindenburg
no one takes any responsibility you see
it on twitter responsibility
nobody takes any any responsibility
none it is one of the biggest problems
with the world right now is
everyone parlays it off onto somebody
else they're like okay you had this this
let's go this way
uh i wasn't me it wasn't it it's
everyone thinks they're [ __ ]
professional
everybody thinks they're way better than
they are everyone thinks they're
owed everything everyone's so entitled
so you have these
entitled people that have these false
senses of
talent it's just delusion like where
we're living and that's why i tell
all my friends like the cream is going
to rise at the top don't worry don't you
worry about your numbers and your
followers like
if you're good it's going to be
blatantly obvious like i
for me i'm i'm not an educated i went to
college for five years didn't finish
uh i went to culinary school blaze
through four five years of college did
it
didn't finish yeah didn't do it yeah you
know people was like i feel that i can
walk in any room on this planet and be
able to
talk to any person on the planet and for
me
it's like moving and grooving now in
this world
i am so for the long game and i've spent
my whole life doing long games that i'm
such a patient
person and the only thing that can screw
that patients up is myself
and i need to have the awareness enough
to be able to understand
exactly to be like just stay to the
course like nick saban trust the process
stick to the course and like if i'm able
if i'm able to just keep the head down
keep on going believe in the process and
keep going and be patient enough
then whatever i really want to achieve
should be able to be achieved like
people donald trump became president of
the united states
anything is possible anything anything
like any anything anything any you
you can do any job i used to say that's
ridiculous like
if you're not born a six foot nine you
know giant
powerful person you you know what you
maybe could
something could happen because
anything's possible now donald trump was
president
that's the only thing that donald trump
did good as president is literally you
could say you can be
anything you want to be anymore that's
the only
advantage i like i like how you talk
about patience too
and um we all get caught in this show
where we want instant gratification
patience is very
very important because patience is also
important for growth
right everything that comes hard is
always better at the end
one of my favorite like and i just want
and i want to wrap it back up to the
food stuff too like my favorite chefs
that i've eaten from are people who have
done their craft for so [ __ ]
long i was waiting for adam perry lane
to open up a restaurant for the longest
time
you know because i just remember he did
pop-ups in l.a or wherever he was at
and people consider him a master smoker
and you know all right
i i went and i ate one of his beef ribs
and i'm like what the [ __ ] did i just
eat
all right you know all right you know
what i've been to texas i've
i've been to all the famous spots and
there's delicious too and then adam
perry lange was like this is something
different what is this [ __ ]
you know and i was like oh he's a master
of his craft and what he
does right there's a reason why his
steaks always look the way that he does
there's a reason why he could talk about
cuts of beef where it comes from the cow
and everything else
and i i really started to appreciate
that patience part right because
his skill set took x amount of years to
get to this point
yes and i always tell people too you
always get what you pay for when it
comes to anything that you do and you
learn it from people who are craftsmen
and
sometimes we hear these yelp reviews not
just with food but things in general
because people don't understand what
they're paying
for right because you could come up to
somebody right let's say something as
simple as this and i learned this from
installing a washer and dryer
my dad did all that stuff i never had to
do it i had installed my own washer and
dryer here
i didn't know [ __ ] about it i hooked it
up and i was like this isn't hot i had
to google it
there's a gas line okay i hooked up the
gas line i didn't use painter's tape i'm
like it's
i didn't use i was like it smells like
gasoline what did i do i had to undo it
and i had to get all these other parts
well the reason why i had to do that and
i didn't pay somebody is because that
person is getting paid for what they
for knowledge for the experience that
they have yes i explained that doing
anywhere in service business i literally
largest septic business for 20 years
pumping septic and it's like
the reason that we charge what we charge
is because we are the best at what we do
the proficiency of me being able to walk
on your yard and know exactly where your
tank is for me to be able to hand dig
these tanks not
using a backhoe being able to dig down
having a cat
being able to dig straight down pop it's
like well i could get somebody else like
no you can't
you're not going to look at this like
you have fun getting the 200
person because you're gonna get what you
pay for i i spent [ __ ]
three days trying to get this washer
this this dryer set up because i didn't
get the right parts i had to wait for
the parts
well if i paid somebody to do it he
would have got it done in 15 minutes
no i agree i'm definitely from my school
so
you know and that's the stuff knowledge
also costs money as well
right challenge is power so when we look
at what somebody else does we say well i
can do what you
do yes you can but it's you're going to
take a while to get there first so
there's a reason why you're paying for
that type of knowledge
it is craftsmanship work right and
though i'm using a very simple example
with just installing your your dryer
it's a great analogy you i didn't know
these things and it took me three days
to get the parts because i didn't
[ __ ] know
so like when when people get these
mickey mouse jobs done on their house
and they start complaining that it's
[ __ ]
it's like you get what you pay for it
happens like that with also without your
worth
yeah you're worth people don't know the
worth nowadays and it took me a decade
to figure out my worth and even with the
show
knowing your worth and being okay and
have the conviction of knowing your work
like
i charge a lot of money to do
to do dinners because i give away all of
my time to charities and all these other
events
whenever i'm cooking i'm going to charge
your ass is it worth every cent
absolutely
it is an incredible experience i'm
having you laugh i mean it's like
listen 50 cents charge 7 000
for freaking super bowl a party per
person like
who even gives a [ __ ] about that and if
he could charge seven thousand i was
like how do you quantify like
any customer that starts to try to
nickel and dime me they're like well
isn't that a little expensive it's like
well tell your husband ask him
where do you quantify the answer of too
expensive i said 185 dollars ahead for
four courses tell me where
where he can get that like tell me where
you're at because we're using we're
using the kobe beef and all this great
stuff that we're doing and i just kind
of want to know where he thinks the 185
is off like where does he get his
numbers from
like tell me where where at what point
they can't like well it just kind of
sounds like you go
till you can go to a freaking club and
drop freaking 100 000
on an ace of spades bottle it's like it
also
my value is what the hell i think my
values and it's your choice to spend
your money on it or not
but i'm not i used to just 35
ahead for a thing this that i'm like
what the [ __ ]
one of the best quotes that i've ever
heard was my prices
aren't based on what you can afford it's
based on what i'm worth
that's one of the the best quotes i've
ever heard
yes and like because people try to
nickel and dime everybody but it comes
with that when you're trying to
train people be like man i don't got any
money it's like
you know that if you don't pay us for
bringing this back right okay
maybe we'll find some money it's like
that's what i thought
my thing is now like i've learned the
hard way from buying shitty things and
getting crappy service i always say this
hey
if you're worth your money make sure
that i don't ever have to see you again
yeah
you know and they always do a great job
it hasn't failed yet
one of my one of my bosses uh
rick o'shea um
said now listen noah i pay a lot of
money
do you know why i pay a lot of money and
i'm like
i i probably guess a couple reasons why
he goes well what do you think i said
i'm going to try to knock this out of
the park with this answer because i
think it is
maybe um you pay a lot of money because
you hire the best and you hire the best
so
you don't have to do that job that you
pay a lot of money for that person to
handle right he goes
elegantly said yes that's exactly right
i pay people money so i don't ever have
to [ __ ] with it noah
if i can if i can pay them money and for
that to be done
that's the whole reason i'm paying them
that money i can pay them less money
but then i have to maybe worry about
them not getting the job done which is
what's the point because i'm getting you
this money for you to complete this said
task yeah if you can't get that job done
what is the point of me paying you
anything
yeah that's a good point i'm trying 100
and when we talk about like these
personal dinners too um
listen i still like mcdonald's i still
eat all this i eat
all the food i eat all that [ __ ] it
doesn't matter just because
you know like i've eaten great food it
doesn't mean i don't eat the same [ __ ] i
grew up with
the thing about like when you go out to
eat right and you're going to a place
for an experience
you're not just paying for the food like
there's there's more to this right right
there's there's a lot more to this and
if you could create this at home
be my guest people don't even want to do
their own [ __ ] dishes when they fry a
[ __ ] egg
you don't see you're so right so what is
this
idea that you this person just created
this dish
that the prep alone took a few days to
do it
you know sourcing out all these
ingredients using all these different
tools and gadgets in here and then you
get this one complete dish
and then you go i can't believe it cost
this much money well guess what there's
no way you would have been able to
create this dish and you would have not
gotten this experience at home
this is what you're paying for if you
want just for nursing
your perfect time you're dead on like if
you want food for nourishment
you can get that at home we could eat an
apple eat some eggs and we're pretty
much good to go
just know what you're paying for you're
right you're a hundred percent this you
say that
hit a nut there's probably a good finish
off point on how much time he got but
um i did a job and i've never not gotten
tipped i
i as god as my witness i'm exceptionally
good at what i do i make people just
feel so good so happy i always go above
and beyond i'm designing every menu is
always different there's never one
i every single dining experience i never
pull a draw
sheet or a spreadsheet every single
one's different every [ __ ] appetizer
there are one-off [ __ ] things and i
take a lot of pride in how i do that
i cook for this freaking group and
to cook five meals in a row for a group
of 15 to 18 people
in a row out of my house that's 24
minutes away from this house having to
go back and forth doing dinner then
brunch then lunch then dinner then lunch
or
breakfast back to back to back to back
to back
setting a price getting them an
incredible bartender world-class
bartender
getting everything done and then for
these people to have still not
paid me all right so now it's been
six days six days since i finished the
job half up front when the job
is started half when it's finished i
have not gotten a tip
i did not get anything these people are
supposed to be millionaires flying in on
lear jets all this stuff
that's crazy they tell me about how
great all the food is epic my dad even
came
out there because i wanted i needed help
uh just doing dishes
my dad's like a world-class dishwasher
he's [ __ ] great washing dishes
um anything he does really he's great at
dishwashing anyways
i mean world-class food some of the best
food
some of the best food i've ever kicked
out in my life
and they still have not finished the
bill
they still owe me like
900. and have not paid me that and then
there's no tip
and it's just like i i tell this person
i did this and
i would normally charge 7 500 because of
how
[ __ ] much work it is to be able to
store all of this food it's not like i'm
doing five meals for four people back to
back to back
this [ __ ] 15 to 18 people that i'm
having to store in a
normal size refrigerator back forth
doing all this
like and i'm doing this and i tell this
person that this would normally be a
seventy five hundred to ten thousand
dollar dinner and i'll do it for five
because of the your friend and who all
this is
but you know just just be like
understand how much of a discount you're
getting and the fact that i'm
that she adds two more people on it i
tell her well
that's going to be that's going to be
333 dollars a person more
you said yes dude two more people yeah
yes yeah two more people
it's like oh yeah i just toss that on
there that i then
literally she's supposed to pick up a
couple things that she wanted and then
my buddy picked him up that was 177 that
she didn't pay me so
they all talk about how this is about a
community and all this stuff and it's me
me me me like what's your super powers
and all this stuff
and then when it comes to the time of
paying me for the first time in my life
there was a customer and as god's mother
i've never had a refi in my professional
career on a steak
ever never i'm talking in restaurants on
game day at uga
not nothing that's really [ __ ] good i
had
i had a refi with these people i had 18
perfect seveted medium rare steaks that
were butter crusted seared off
flawless you know how hard it is to cook
[ __ ] 18 fillets
by yourself and nail them perfect they
were nailed on it
this woman like ah i know i said minnie
more but could you go a little bit more
i took a picture just to make sure i
wasn't losing my [ __ ] mind
make sure i was looking at a perfect
medium rare probably bright ruby when
you seveda steak properly when you sear
it off you got that perfect crust
yeah and it's just this ruby red and
it's perfect
so i fired off to meet him bring it back
she's like
i hate to be difficult but can i get
this just a little bit more
like okay fired off the well and i'm
like
sitting here being like these people one
of these people held a plate up
like i'm some servant [ __ ] to come by
and pick up the plate i about took it
like a frisbee and threw it through the
glass because like
you all know like what what the [ __ ] is
going on here and it's like
those people ran me like a
dog and i
don't do any marketing before i signed
with this person that was this
collection
before i signed with this person i never
had one single person nickel and dime me
never had
one person question what my worth was i
was it is what it was
as soon as i get with this freaking
realtor all that's happened is people
call me email me nickel and dime me
people just
it's like they're the richest of the
rich people and it's like
it's do you think it's telling me a
little bit about like society that the
richest of the rich people keep trying
to pick on the little guy that's like
so what's happened to me i hammer down
my self-worth i'm self-aware i don't
give a [ __ ] what you think i am worth
you rich bastard
yeah i am this and either you're gonna
pay me
or you're not getting it and good luck
finding somebody that can do a tenth of
what i can do
yeah you know like it goes right back to
the point of understanding what your
value is and not
bending on it like you're like you said
like
what what you think i'm worth has no
effect if you want if you think i'm
worth it great pay me if not
goodbye have a good day yeah and it's
not a disrespect no
it's a respect to me correct knowing
your self-worth
yeah the self-awareness on that i feel
nothing about you
but i understand that you feel that way
but i can't change that but i know
the time and practice it took for me to
create these dishes
and what i do so i can't
i can't dumb myself down because of how
you
feel how you feel these things
perception
it's like you might think buying a rolex
is great for business
i'm going to be like what the [ __ ] are
you doing it's like it's
always perception it's like people get
so upset it's like
all right toodles like you don't think
i'm more than great i know that i'm
literally booked
all month yeah i'm [ __ ] slammed i
wish i wasn't so
booked like i wish i but i'm a stud and
i want to keep working as hard as i can
and work and get through it
and i don't overtake too much where i
start to getting down in
product i i have to be able to balance
where i'm still giving a 100
product of where i want to be never
where i get too busy where i start
cutting down on my product because my
product is my word
my bond like every time i never get too
much work where i start getting the work
hurt
ever that's what my dad taught me always
keep
work if you can work 20 hours and keep
it up to 100
do it if you can't don't do it figure
out where you can keep it the maximum
it's like what sims do we just [ __ ]
try to maximize
get on that cusp and just get on the
precipice and just kind of dance and
have a little soiree on that line
so i digress but there we are
i mean for you i mean before we end this
podcast if somebody wanted to get into
i'd say like culinary right whether it's
opening up a restaurant becoming a
personal chef
what is your advice to give to them
because um
i think a lot of people have a
fascination with food now right
and i think that they don't really ask
the right people
right so they ask people who don't have
the experience or maybe
not even that just the passion for food
in general so if you want to
if you could give advice to a young
person that was saying like look i've
been watching all these tick tock videos
i'm inspired to cook
what should i do to get into either the
food industry or what should i do to
become a better chef
this is a really this will be it's a
good closing question that's a great
closing question
so if you could listen to one thing that
i was going to tell you on this podcast
it would be this because
not just in culinary but in this world
people are destinationless
they just are going through the motions
without actually understanding
where they're heading so in the culinary
field
and in other steps in life having a
destination
is so key to be able to achieve
all of said goals that you laid down
i believe destination is like one nail
in the tree
and then you're holding the other nail
and you string it up and you're able to
dry out your clothes and if you don't
if you don't get your clothesline hung
up on a good support over there
then your clothes are going to fall and
never dry like you're not going to get
anything done but if you get a good
foundation over there and you know where
you're at right here that self-awareness
having that self-awareness is so
freaking key because how the hell are
you supposed to know where you can go if
you don't know who you are
how do you supposed to know where the
hell you need to go if you don't know
who you are
like that's where people get in the
wrong places doing the wrong things
because they didn't know where the hell
they were at with themselves like
how are you supposed to get to the
destination if you don't know where your
true location is
when you're in the gps on your phone
you're like my current location
and now i'm going to go here if you
don't know where your current location
is how the hell
are you going to get to that destination
so many people overlook that they don't
think about like i really need to know
where the hell i'm at now like
if if you're a if you're a sushi you
know rice master of two years you
probably can progress
into becoming a sushi master because you
spent your two years the guy that hadn't
spent the two years be like i want to
become a sushi master
well where are you you haven't even
begun your journey yet yet you start
stating these things so many people
don't have the patience or the
self-awareness to understand so in
culinary
if you want to own if you want to own
a freaking little cottage in ireland and
cook
what do you need to do to be able to
make that
shake like what do you need to do your
destination
set you want to be in galway you want to
open a badass restaurant got it
what steps you need to do subdivide
those steps
break down the analytics on every step
that you think you need to do
and keep self-awareness on all of those
steps you're like okay well i was wrong
here so clearly if i'm wrong here
it's like sudoku look at it like sudoku
if i have the nine here sure [ __ ] ain't
gonna be over here
like look at life like sudoku it should
line up and whenever you get it right
if you're paying attention you should be
able to make the puzzle shake
just fine so for me the advice would be
understand where the hell you're going
understand where you're at
and then understand the key the biggest
key
do what makes you happy like it doesn't
matter
nothing matters if you're not happy like
what makes me happy what my destination
is
what it is just to change the world it
doesn't matter my destination is
earth right now and people like what
does it mean so vague
if i'm in front of people helping people
and i keep moving forward it does not
matter i don't have to have a
destination because
i i'm happy where i'm at right now i've
met my destination
my destination is right here at this
moment like
my purpose is here i don't have to i
used to think
15 years down the road at this time in
my life
that is wound down to right now because
i need to focus
at the moment this is where i need to be
i've accomplished to hear
i don't need to feel like i need to keep
going to be more accomplished because so
many people have that false sense of i
got to keep going got to keep going got
to keep going
they can't just enjoy the moment right
now which is what i used to do
all the time and not just savor
the moment you've got to be able to
understand that to be able to be
happy you have to be you you have to be
able to
have that self-awareness to realize like
things are good
like i'm enjoying myself like this is
okay do i need to keep going
yeah but that's okay like me losing
weight i
i've lost 130 pounds do i need to lose
30 more
more pounds now probably about 10 more
pounds old noah would have been totally
pissed like you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
loser like finish the [ __ ] drill
this mature no it's like all right man
you've done pretty [ __ ] good you've
lost 100 something pounds like
we're getting better things are on the
up and up and it's like
having that destination i still got it
in my head on my body
but for my happiness i'm just [ __ ]
just
totally fine i've reached my destination
i'm happy and like
that's the key to anything in life to be
able to be successful is
happiness yeah i believe if you're not
[ __ ] with anybody if you're not
making someone else's life
miserable if you're not doing anything
that's negative to somebody and you're
happy
that's it god doesn't want to there's
there's nothing else
like like people are stupid like well
what about the bills
what about this you don't understand
like your brain can't come
if you're happy then you're happy
like if you're not having negative
impact on people and you're happy
willfully happy winning
you're winning like what else is there
there's nothing else
like some people might need a ferrari to
make them happy
some person might not he just sitting
under a tree
being totally fine drinking a coca-cola
whoever it doesn't matter if you're
happy on a jet airliner that your
private jet
great if you're happy swimming with your
kid
in the freaking pool great like
god's happy for this guy god's happy for
this guy
because they're happy yeah and that's
the whole goal like that's my whole goal
my destination
is happy town like that's the big one
right now we're at a place everything
else is space in this world
okay a place is something that you know
the destination like i am at a place
right now in my life where i'm not just
floating around like i have purpose
here everything has purpose in your life
if you look for it
you'll be able to see it and for me this
journey
the journey that we're on what you what
you talked about having
having patience and then it gives you
that perseverance it's like
like keep going just have that faith and
like have that
have that end game like what is gonna
make me
happy my grandma always said that like
what makes you happy helping people then
then do it do it like who like do it
like
work your ass off like that would be my
advice work your ass off and be happy
like just don't worry about the money
when you're happy the money will come if
you're the best at
what you do in your in your business
you'll have money you don't have to
worry about that
i think it's very important like i like
the uh because everybody talks about
destination but they don't talk about
where they start correct
and if you don't know where you start
you're not gonna know where the
destination is in the first place
because you have nothing to base
anything off no bearings you don't have
your bearings
yeah and it goes really well with food
too it's like you have to know what
you're good at and what you're bad at
correct you can't just go right into a
kitchen to see what the [ __ ] happens
right like you're never going to get
anywhere
right correct cool 100 no that was
really good hey
where can they find you man uh you can
find me on
uh instagram uh that is mountain
underscore man underscore sims
i thought it looked really cool when i
came up with that and it really is
taking off people love that name but i
am a mountain man like
i mean i could rambo it i can get a
knife and go survive
in the woods like i feel very confident
in my survival
tracking abilities uh but yeah you can
get me on
i don't do the tick tock thing uh not
not a tick tocker i tried to
do a funny video on that and i just like
this is not my jam at all
i'm a big instagram guy i love instagram
facebook richard noah sims
s-i-m-s thank you so much for having me
on here i'm so glad to be out in la
uh hopefully we can probably get some
big bold beautiful flavored food
tomorrow i think i'm pretty much
open tomorrow dinner time keep it open
before
you get on this flight 100 we could uh
we're going to go to thai town
and we're just going to get a fat
[ __ ] spread i mean it's fat spread
drinks
food noodle soups right dish meat
everything i'm just going to be good i'm
in
i mean dude i live i live
for for connections conversations and
eating good food and breaking
where i'm from we call it supper having
supper uh
and like breaking breaking bread and
having a good supper
uh i mean i'm always all about that i'm
all about the connections and bringing
humanity closer and trying to
[ __ ] you know kick the [ __ ] out of
evil people and weak people and bigoted
people and all that stuff so
uh this has been fantastic i appreciate
your time for sure well you guys can
catch genius brain every thursdays and
sundays and we'll see you all next time
everybody
peace peace guys